what do you think about how the media
and everything that's going on is
handling Kanye West
I don't know man you know he's
apologetic you know Kanye West my
brother my family I'm not here to make
excuses or you know dig into his
situation
uh you know I support him
and uh
you know something's gonna be taken out
of text obviously the same guy they used
for clout and they use to make clothes
and make money off
now they just drop them in embarrass
them publicly because
you know it's the same stories you know
same Toilet Man different [ __ ] is just a
lot of [ __ ] piled up you know and you
know when [ __ ] pile up it gets smelly
you know it gets stink gets stopped up
and it's you know somebody got a dress
it somebody got to be the plumber so I
command my brother yay and don't call
him Kanye call him yay you know I
commend my brother yay you know for
being so courageous
and uh consider it because it take a lot
of courage and uh
is lit maybe what do you think was a
Tipping Point I don't know what a
Tipping Point I can't talk for yay I'm
not here to represent yeah I represent
donde yay represent yay and um that's my
friend just send him encouragement
I mean what do you feel like how do you
how would you feel if your bank account
got canceled what would you do and be
furious I I don't you want to know how
to feel you wouldn't know how to feel
you're just making an imagination or
assumption well yes you wouldn't know
what to do I'm saying so you're making
the logic on yours man yeah it's it's
it's a it's a no it's a scary situation
for a lot of people how do you feel
about how Elon made the phone call
and he said I spoke to him he was
apologetic and we're gonna move on and
he didn't do anything to him since he's
now you know owning and running Twitter
how do you think about the way Elon
handled with uh yay
yeah Ron parlor
log on to parlor out
you know I can't speak for no one else
man you know
you want me to say I can't speak for no
one else or what no one else did I don't
know I can't judge no one actions what
do you think is yeah Kanye's motivation
at this point because I've seen him
can't tell you his motivation man I
don't I don't I'm not in his head but
hey B you're a smart dude bro it's not
like you're immune from what's going on
there you must say let me get your
assumption you tell me I'ma ask you two
questions you are the president of his
sports agency correct they've shown that
down of course correct you're also a
musician Fox yes you do you you collabs
you've done collabs you said you've done
more collabs more features Rick Ross the
baby French Montana Sean Kingston uh you
did a thing with young thug by the way
get my bag sick thing and then you got
people dancing Keyshia Cole yeah I've
seen all this so you do have some
insight brother as far as listen man
what's going on with yeah
music goes man he got a lot more things
that's important that's bigger than
music right now
you're not waiting on them to get on you
know you get some homework done as well
but you know the time we had we got War
right now man just to be encouraging to
be the light you say you're at War
we at War we are people who is we we're
too
ourselves the world
when you say the people what do you mean
we who are the people we you're saying
Americans you're saying black Americans
you're saying oh Americans everyone bro
black white everyone everyone's at War
we're trying to figure out how to have a
better world how to come together how to
give more opportunities for the future
it's not an individual thing you know
it's not something you can single out we
all here as one kind
human
you know what I mean
so Kanye views himself I'm not here to
speak for Kanye how he view himself you
gotta ask yay I'm I'm a B I can't speak
for you or how he think and what he
views up you've seen the interviews
you're seeing what he put out support
him okay with all due respect maybe yeah
I work with Pat every single day every
day because we I I co-host his podcast I
work for valuetainment this is my guy
right he hired me just like Yay hired
you to be the president if you asked me
if Pat was dealing with something and
you asked me but this is what I'm saying
yeah but listen you talk about a guy who
canceled from his bank account to his
shoe account so what do you want me to
say I don't know what do you want I
don't I can't tell you how you ain't
thinking in a time where he in his own
head and own space I don't know what
it's like to lose two billion dollars in
one of the day one day you don't know
what it's like so I'm not here to make
an assumption who do I know what it
feels like
I don't know when everyone follow you
when they turn you I gotta know what I
feel like when they follow when they
turn your back on you like when they say
if you don't play You're Gonna you're
gonna get CT if you play but if you
don't play maybe you got hit and had CTE
you know what I mean the same thing with
him have you spoke with him recently nah
man we got War man it's better you know
better for positive actions
a lot of communications are non-verbal
okay so you think it's a better idea to
just kind of distance yourself or just
kind of nah I love Yeah everywhere yeah
we yeah but I don't mean distance
yourself like no I mean like he's
dealing with some stuff let him deal
with it you're dealing with your own
your own life we support them we stand
next to him we need more support people
say they outside we need more people to
come outside all color people everyone
everyone man this is this is about
making it better as a whole for we could
live better yeah I mean I hear you bro
but if you weren't as well if you
weren't president of his Sports World
Sports company can't even play
basketball right now what do you want me
to tell you it's not about yeah it's
about the freaking kids kids missing
opportunities you asking me about yay so
clearly you don't care about what the
opportunities for the future of the kids
you only care about what Kanye thinks
because that's what make your ratings
that's what you're gonna piggyback off
the clock to make the height it's not a
person who thinks it's a reality thing
that's why I try to be funny with the
truth because the truth hurt it may make
people insensitive it made people feel
bad it may change your the motor out of
the environment because it's untrue it's
true it hurts okay it's sad so let me
you don't even care about the kids that
done the sports that can't play because
they can't go to school to school
clothes it don't even matter about them
right it just matter about what yay feel
about it what about the kids that got to
go to school
what are the kids that go to you're
saying there's a donda Academy you're
saying no no what happened with the kids
is the kids that are tied to it their
scholarship to the universities was cut
Jalen Brown just tweeted earlier today
saying the fact that the kids were
represented by them are now losing their
scholarship doesn't make any sense and
then people went after Jalen Brown which
why would the kids be affected by this
okay you see what I'm saying we're here
focused on the guy yeah who's the
biggest guy in the world who everyone
wanna
it's not about what he acts man it's a
conversation it's not right or wrong
this is we're good bro this is
communication I'm not even gonna ask you
what about the kids about who can't go
to the next level because of this moment
it's not fair to them you see what I'm
saying yeah it's not fair to those kids
you see what I'm saying if there's
anybody that that doesn't want to see
that happen this guy grew up I'm not
saying you guys don't want to see
everyone's succeed I'm just saying uh
the communication or or the focus of
what's important I understand the little
things in the world like yeah say oh
slavery was
an option sure oh White lives not matter
but then he just get canceled out the
blue so it's like what's important in
these times we don't know could we have
a Kumbaya could we find out because I'm
just hearing like yo I got kids that
losing
opportunities to change their lives and
we're here talking about what you think
about getting cut from a brand and
getting his face ruined then
you see what I'm saying like we missed
the point of the realistic of the
importance but that's the world that's
not any of you guys fault you know what
I'm saying that's just the world and
what we in so we have these conversation
these topics to show that how we can
make it better even if it's
uncomfortable even if people don't
understand even if you feel like it's
um you know what I mean that's why I try
to be funny about the truth because the
truth could be aggressive you know
imagine poking a bear it's like going to
the animal caves you know the lion cage
in it you know
well I think look I'm not sure if you
don't want to talk Connie went on Conway
but if you're president of down to
sports
hey man we want to talk about the kids
the kids that deserve opportunities but
beyond the kids that's missing
opportunities but maybe beyond the case
about the years there's also athletes
like it's about to use Aaron about the
youth no matter athlete Aaron Donald and
Jalen Brown they you know what I'm
saying they they not they cancel
you know they they you know they show
their hand we respect those guys in
their decision we support those guys but
it's about the kids it's about the
brighter future powering God's up for
the for the how we gonna obtain the
mission of the future superheroes when
we stopping opportunities one apple [ __ ]
and swore the whole tree
one misunderstanding shouldn't you know
why are we canceling people why are we
the only one getting canceled so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]